[cattle moo]
- I got some leather here.
- What?
- I’ll hold the tail
for you, Dusty.
What that was,
about an eight-footer?
- That’s a man-eater
right there, huh?
- Look at that big old snake!
That’s a beautiful skin.
- Make you a jacket, Mr. Troy?
- Oh, look. You ever had
python gumbo, bro?
- Hey, the python’s good.
Might have to work
something out, huh, Troy?
Maybe we can trade, you know.
I’d like to get
some of them gator skins.
- We can get you some
gator skins, that’s for sure.
Turn around a minute. Look.
See what I’m saying?
Put that down the back
of a jacket, whoo!
[all laugh]
Every pattern is different?
- Yeah. Yeah, it’s crazy.
It’s like a fingerprint.
Every pattern’s different.
- Does she lay eggs in a nest?
She makes her nest with eggs?
- Yeah.
- Didn’t you say
the other day
that one of these,
the big one had 83--
- Yeah, 83 eggs.
- [whistles]
- Do you think these snakes
will migrate?
- Oh, yeah. They’re moving
every direction.
- Really?
- North, south, east and west.
They’re moving down into
the Keys in the saltwater.
They go through the saltwater,
it don’t affect them.
We got endangered wood rats
down there.
We got Key deer
that are endangered.
And they get in
them islands, man,
it’s gonna be hard
to get ’em out of there.
- I know we drove around
over there at night
till 2:00, 3:00
in the morning.
You don’t see an animal.
- In Orlando somewhere,
they had a pet snake.
It got out of the room,
went into the baby’s room,
into the crib,
and ate the damn baby.
- Got the 911 call.
- They ain’t no way, bro,
I’d have that in my house
with a child.
I wouldn’t have it
in my house no way.
- Look, what do I got to do
to work out a trade, you know?
I wanna take some of these
gators home with me
and skin ’em out and tan ’em.
- How many you want?
One? Two?
- Hey, as many as I can get.
- We got almost 1,000.
- If I fill up
the back of my truck,
I’ll be good.
- Yep. We can make a deal,
buddy.
I’d love to have
one of them nice skins.
Hell, yeah, baby,
let’s make a deal!